Speaker 1: Well, a huge deal was made yesterday
about a speech from the failed former president
Donald Trump in Washington, D.C.
It was billed as his triumphant and defiant
return to Washington, D.C..
Of course, it didn't quite go as planned.
Number one, it happened under the cloud, figuratively,
of a criminal federal investigation into the
former president.
We learned about that yesterday as Donald
Trump was giving his speech almost quite literally.
The speech was for the America First Policy
Institute.
This is one of these nonprofit political nonprofits,
and it was created essentially around Trump.
Trump was inaugurated in 2017.
He would talk about America first.
Then they created the America First Policy
Institute.
It's sort of supposed to appear to be kind
of a think tank.
It's just a wacky, wacky organization.
And Trump gave this much promoted speech and
it was whacked.
Trump went full, deep state conspiracy theories.
Trump pretended to be transgender.
It was a complete and utter implosion.
And we are going to look at and this is one
of the most deranged speeches that Donald
Trump has ever given.
And it's deranged for two reasons.
Number one, the speech lacks all context for
what happened during Trump's presidency and
for the fact that he's currently under criminal
investigation.
It's sort of like a just fantasy world speech.
Number two, it is stunning the degree of authoritarianism
that is supposed small government movement
now casually demands.
And we will get to that part of the speech
as well.
Part of it is Trump saying, we just got to
make it easy to fire people.
And here he pulls out the deep state conspiracy
theory.
Speaker 3: And the swamp and root out the
deep state.
We need to make it much easier to fire rogue
bureaucrats who are deliberately undermining
democracy, which or at a minimum, just want
to keep their jobs.
They want to hold onto their jobs.
Congress should pass historic reforms, empowering
the president to ensure that any bureaucrat
who is corrupt, incompetent or unnecessary
for the job can be told.
Did you ever hear this?
You're fired.
Get out.
You have to do it.
Deep state.
Speaker 1: Deep state.
Deep State is a conspiracy theory of a sort
of clandestine network of actors involved
in the federal government, involved in industry,
involved in high level finance, and they operate
as a kind of hidden government.
Specifically, Deep State is sort of a Trump
aligned conspiracy theory, but the idea of
a shadow government that is really pulling
the strings, that's a very, very old conspiracy
theory.
It's often highly anti-Semitic involving that.
It's actually the Jews pulling the strings.
There are many versions of it, and Trump has
bought into it.
This is a this is straight up conspiracy theory,
whack job stuff.
Often there will be some kernel of truth to
hang on to.
And the kernel of truth is.
People with money tend to have power in the
United States.
That is true.
And it has been blown up into this supposed
anti-Trump deep cover conspiracy theory.
And Trump just openly talking about it now.
Now, Trump also regularly, overtly transphobic
now during his speeches, he did it here as
well.
And here in this clip, Donald Trump pretends
to lift weights first, impersonating, I guess,
what he believes to be a, quote, real female
weightlifter and then impersonating a trans
weightlifter.
This is a staple now of Trump's.
Speaker 3: Speeches even saying he can lift.
I don't know about that, Kevin, but that's
a lot.
£218.
And she got over that weight and she was going
to break and they put a half an ounce here,
half little tiny ring on top of these big
barbells, dumbbells.
And they go and she went like this and she
got stood for 11 years.
And her mother and father are screaming, You
got it, you got it, darling.
I'm so proud of my girl.
Uh oh.
I thought she couldn't do it.
And then.
This guy comes along.
His name Dallas.
And he looks at the way
the world record.
World record.
We could have put another couple of hundred
pounds on.
I think he would have left her.
Speaker 1: So regularly misgendering people.
Ridiculing trans athletes, by the way, inventing
scenarios that are completely imaginary.
And this is now overtly acceptable in these
contexts.
This is this America First Policy Institute.
It's supposed to be more of a buttoned up,
serious policy think tank arm of the delusional
Trumpist MAGA America First nonsense.
And it's not turning out that way because
Trump is on stage pretending to be trans.
Now, continuing the horrible authoritarianism,
Trump announces his plan for the homeless,
and it's basically to create tent cities where
you put homeless people in tents.
Speaker 3: All kinds from all places lying
along the roads.
That's without the tents.
And then you look at the tents and the homeless
and you say, what's happening to this great
bastion?
Perhaps some people will not like hearing
this, but the only way you're going to remove
the hundreds of thousands of people and may
be throughout our nation, millions of people
were just.
Speaker 1: Now two things here.
One, they are now also selling gold coins
alongside Trump's speech on Newsmax.
And secondly, understand the absurdity.
Trump bemoans the horrible nature of homeless
people living in tents in cities.
And his solution is make homeless people live
in tents outside of cities.
That's the solution.
Speaker 3: I care about and help make our
cities clean, safe and beautiful again is
opened up large parcels of inexpensive land
at the outer reaches of the cities bring medical
professionals, including doctors, psychiatrists,
psychologists.
Speaker 1: All the medical professionals Trump
ignored for four years during COVID rehab.
Speaker 3: Specialists build permanent bathrooms
and other facilities.
Make them good, make them hard.
Speaker 1: You need you think you need your
shower.
And you need your third, third element of
the bathroom.
Speaker 3: But build them fast and create
thousands and thousands of high quality tents,
which can be done in one day, one day.
And you have to move people out.
Now, some people say, oh, that's so horrible.
No, what's horrible is what's happening now.
Speaker 1: Right.
So Trump really displeased with all of the
homeless people living in tents in cities.
We've got to do something for them.
We really do.
So we're going to move them to tents outside
of the cities and the tents will be a little
bit better.
And we will have doctors there.
Really, really wild, authoritarian stuff.
Trump Then of course, going through his pity
me part of the speech where he said he's been
treated even worse than Richard Nixon, I guess
that's the point he's trying to make.
Speaker 3: Who else could have taken this?
You know, think of it.
Nixon went through not even one impeachment.
And I think he always regretted that he didn't
fight.
But people.
It's been a very interesting period of time.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Just treated so terribly.
Trump, you know, subjected to multiple impeachments
that even Nixon didn't go through that.
At another point in the speech, Donald Trump
claimed that we charge the country $25,000
for each person that comes in illegally.
I assume he means we bill the source country.
So like if a mexican person comes in illegally,
we bill Mexico for 25 grand of.
Speaker 3: All of the bad ones, and the police
know almost immediately who the bad ones are
and that we could do and that we can do fast
and easy.
At the same time, we should implement a bond
system and a financial penalty so that anyone
who comes to our country on a temporary visa
and fails to depart suffers significant financial
consequences.
And we take the money away from the country.
We charge the country $25,000 each for each
person that comes in illegally.
Speaker 1: Notice that there's almost no policy
during these bizarre speeches.
But when you get something that sounds like
policy, it's, number one, completely absurd
and obviously unworkable diplomatically.
And also the crowd claps because they don't
seem to know any better at all.
At another moment, Donald Trump talked about
Democratic Congressman Adam Schiff and Trump's
increasingly focused on Schiff's personal
appearance and the shape of Schiff's head,
referring to it regularly now to be watermelon
shaped.
Speaker 3: And it's dessert.
Think of this.
These are hacks and folks who the same people
that we've been dealing with for four years,
same people.
And it's the very people who perpetrated the
lies that I was an agent of Russia, like Adam
Schiff, Joseph and others were standing before
the same microphone, same thing.
They get out and they say, oh, our country
is suffering so badly because and he knows
the whole thing is a hoax.
I said this the other day.
He knew Russia.
Russia was a hoax, him, Hillary Clinton, the
DNC, the Democrats.
And he stood pompously before microphones
his head.
As you know, I feel a shaped like a watermelon.
Speaker 1: Trump's head is really small, by
the way.
Speaker 3: He's a quite unattractive man.
Now, see, that'll get me in trouble for that,
Kellyanne, because by saying he's unattractive,
they'll say, that's a horrible thing to say.
But he said slightly worse about me.
Right.
And it's right.
Speaker 1: He did even worse.
Okay.
So then we go into the full authoritarian
part of the speech where Trump again has this
almost like a wet dream of sending military
into cities to, quote, restore order despite
the governor's wishes all of a sudden not
super concerned with states rights.
Speaker 3: Where there is a true and total
breakdown of law and order, where citizens
most basic rights have been violated, then
the federal government can and should send
the National Guard to restore order and secure
the peace without having to wait for the approval
of some governor that thinks it's politically
incorrect to call.
Speaker 1: The party of states rights, says
we should be allowed to send in the military
whenever we want.
Speaker 3: But, man, when governors refuse
to protect their people, we need to bring
in what's necessary anyway.
We have to go beyond the governor.
Another 60 people were shot.
Think of this.
It's not even possible.
We shot in Chicago over the weekend.
Yes, enough.
Speaker 1: With many, many with firearms that
whose providence is originally purchases in
the neighboring state of Indiana with very
lax gun laws.
Speaker 3: I stand for 18 months.
Not one of our soldiers was killed.
And they had that number of people shot in
Chicago over the weekend.
Think of it.
Hmm.
And he died, by the way.
Many died when that video shot.
A lot of going to die.
And this is constant in Chicago, and this
cannot go on anymore.
Every other approach has been considered and
tried.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
You know, the thing that hasn't been tried
is actually dealing with the guns.
But Trump wants to send in the troops.
Very, very small government, states rights,
conservative.
Okay.
Last couple of things after to go back to
the trans part.
Anti-trans is such a big part now of Trump
speeches.
When Trump finishes up a rant attacking trans
youth and trans athletes.
He says his idea for winning with a basketball
team would be to convince LeBron James to
be a woman.
Speaker 3: So unfair.
It's so unfair.
And I'll tell you what, if I were ever, I'd
be the greatest women's basketball coach in
history.
Because I don't like LeBron James.
I like Michael Jordan much better.
Oh, but I. Oh, but I'd go up to LeBron James.
It doesn't matter.
I say LeBron, did you ever have any desire
to be a woman?
Because what I'd love for you to do is star
on my team that I'm building up.
I will have the greatest team in history.
They'll never lose nobody who will come within
70 points of this team.
And we have to change that and we have to
make it okay to talk about it.
You know, the young lady I was talking about
is afraid to talk about it.
She's shunned and she's canceled when she
talks about it.
Speaker 1: Yep.
So there's Trump's big idea for basketball.
And then lastly, just maybe the dumbest part
of the speech all together.
Trump rants about windshield wipers.
Speaker 3: True.
I said, I can't talk about it.
I complained.
I said, I did too good a job.
I did too good a job that's like obsolescence,
you know, a windshield wiper for those of
you I used to drive cars haven't been driving
too many lately, but for those for those of
you that complain, you buy a windshield wiper.
Right.
And it lasts for one year and then it doesn't
work anymore.
You can't see.
You got to get another one.
They could make the wiper good for 100 years,
but they want planned obsolescence.
The same thing is happening now.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I guess Trump doesn't realize
you just grab a paper towel, you pinch your
wiper and wipe it, and then it's like back
to you.
But, you know, we I guess I can't expect Trump
to know that.
So under a cloud of a criminal federal investigation
against Trump, he shows up to deliver what
was supposed to be this historic, triumphant,
defiant, principled speech.
And he rants about trans athletes, authoritarian,
wet dreams of sending the National Guard in
to democratic states and windshield wipers.
Folks, this guy could be the next president.
We'll have these clips on our Instagram, which
you can find at David Pakman show.